the Fingerprints of trump cronies are
just all over the Brazilian Insurrection
attempt that is going on we spoke
earlier in the show of the imagery from
Brazil over the last 48 hours which
looks just like the imagery from January
6 2021 in the United States and
Washington D.C protesters with flags
different flags yes breaking down police
barriers and overwhelming police to get
into legislative buildings in the U.S it
was mostly the House of Representatives
in Brazil they were in the Senate the
federal Senate extraordinary
similarities and it's important to go
back and really understand how this all
came to be something that people thought
of doing in this particular way at this
particular time when it happened here in
the United States
the organizers the Insiders the
inspirers were not punished in any real
way oh I know kiwanan Shaman and the
people who uh you know broke a window
they were punished but the people who
were uh fomenting the Insurrection at
the top level at least for now have not
been held accountable we'll see what
happens the January 6 committee which is
now disbanded has submitted its report
we'll see what Merrick Garland decides
about charges but it's not just oh look
they did it in the U.S that's something
we could do as I told you in the earlier
part of the show
Trump aides Steve Bannon and Jason
Miller wait was it Jason Miller or
Stephen Miller
that's actually a good question Jason it
is Jason Miller okay Trump AIDS Stephen
Bannon and Jason Miller were advising
the bolsonaros on what are the next
steps this is an article from November
of 2022 in the Washington Post
uh while tens of thousands of supporters
of bolsonaro Camp outside military
facilities across Brazil to protest his
election loss members of bolsonaro's
inner circle are meeting with advisors
to former president Donald Trump
to discuss next steps Brazilian
Congressman Eduardo bolsonaro the
president's son has visited Florida
since the October 30th vote meeting
Trump at Mar-A-Lago strategizing with
other political allies by phone look at
this he spoke with former Trump
strategist Stephen Bannon who was in
Arizona Helping Kerry Lake about the
power of the pro bolsonaro protests and
potential challenges to the Brazilian
election Bannon said election results
Bannon said sounds pretty similar he
lunched in South Florida with former
Trump campaign spokesman Jason Miller
now CEO of the social media company
getter and discussed online censorship
and Free Speech neither Trump nor
Eduardo bolsonaro responded to requests
for comment and then of course we have
all sorts of interesting videos that we
can look at first we look at Donald
Trump's address to the people of Brazil
this was right before the vote starting
to talk with the San same language it
would really be bad for your country if
you let bolsonaro lose and I just have
to say that I'm very proud of your last
vote and we'll be even more proud of
your current vote October 30th right
because you have a chance to elect one
of the Great
people in all of politics and all of
leadership of countries he's respected
by everybody other leaders I can tell
you including myself respect him at the
highest level president bolsonaro he is
doing a fantastic job for your country
he's bringing it back like nobody could
and I just say he has my complete and
total endorsement he's a great man he
loves his country and let him do his job
Brazil is taking a whole new place in
the world you're being respected all
over the world because of your president
Now understand that's the same incorrect
stuff that he would say about himself
The Playbook is identical the world
finally respects the United States under
me Donald Trump no you look at Gallup
polling and other than Russia and Turkey
I believe it was the world respects the
US less than than ever under Donald
Trump and similarly the world has mostly
been horrified had mostly been horrified
when President bolsonaro was indeed
president
oh we lost the video
all right
quite a glitch all right well no problem
you get the gist of it we then go to
November 2nd November 2nd when Mike
Lindell also known as Mike pillow the
CEO and founder of my pillow says hey
I'm actually friends with Eduardo
bolsonaro and my cyber guys have been
watching it and it was all rigged it's
the same language here it's all the same
inputs so you end up with the same
output everybody remember we were
watching the Brazil election oh yeah
cyber guys for watching and uh they took
that we know that we know of was 5.1
million votes
and uh through the machines remember
everybody over there is Brandon looks
for that in Brazil I'm friends with
their uh um the president's son Eduardo
barcenero he's also barcenero by the way
it's the same stuff right the machines
my cyber guys five million votes it's
all wacky a friend of the stage
sent there that day and he they tried to
get paper put in where at least the
machines would would you hit a button
and it would print out a paper copy so
that you could do an audit that got
voted down by the corrupt judges so the
the judges over there voted that down we
don't want a paper trail so they have
peer machines everybody when I say pure
machine there's no paper it's just a tab
boom boom boom boom so whatever that
tells you whatever program's inside
here's who won game
so it's the exact same stuff that he's
been saying here it's it's the same
Playbook guys it's all the same Bannon
said the same stuff pillow said the same
stuff Trump that said the same stuff
it's all the same stuff we go now from
November 2nd to November 20th at that
point pillow was ready to make even
Bolder claims which were Brazil's
Supreme Court actually rigged the
election he was ready to be more more
bold in his claims these back up on
getting paper
so they they they
um whether they blackmail corrupt
um threatened whatever they did are
these uh convinced some of them let's
say convinced I don't know how they
convinced them to
yeah
um and then we got to November 23rd at
which point Stephen Bannon was straight
up trying to instigate a coup in Brazil
look in the streets of Brazil look at
the great patrons in Brazil that had a
lot of danger to themselves have come
forward or in the streets of Brazil and
quite frankly as much as I love the
bolsonares and Ed water I think is going
to speak tomorrow there's no better man
on this globe than Edward of Boston or
his father in Brazil it's gone beyond
the Bolson hours this is the people
saying no you didn't follow the
Constitution you use these machines use
the Judiciary to shut us down in the
media and we're not going to tolerate it
it's going to be very interesting to see
how that plays out same in the United
States you know the people like Kerry
Lake are not going to give up and I use
as a warning and the great fight that
you guys ever in front of you both for
the cultural issues for the political
issues and the economic issues once they
start taking and digitizing the
elections once they start going to
machines where you can't get paper
ballot you don't have proof of ID you
take it away from the precincts and they
start to centralize it in collection
centers that's all done for one reason
dad's to consistently steal elections so
it's the same the same bullet points
same talking points this is uh the it's
it's fascistic rhetoric and you know
that was November 23rd and listen to
Bannon saying it was interesting Kerry
Lake's not going to give up Kerry Lake's
not going to give up Kerry Lake's not
going to give up and indeed she has kept
going and going and going and going
despite the fact that she lost and
that's the idea you don't allow the
election results to get in the way of
you taking power because that's all that
matters at the end of the day it's
extraordinarily dangerous so we're going
to move on from the topic of Brazil for
today and we'll continue to track what
happens but I think it's important to
say that
we need to watch very closely
how or if this is handled differently in
Brazil than it was in the United States
and we saw the the buses busloads of
people getting arrested right away and
that's good
we'll see if the military makes a
broader statement about there's nothing
here Lula's the legal president that's
it we're behind Lula we're going to
track all of it we'll see where the
differences are and subsequently we'll
be able to say what the different
outcomes are and the impact on the
country and the U.S we're ripe for
another one of these because the
instigators have not been punished uh
we'll see if Brazil handles it in a
different way